[BEEP]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
EMILY: Hello, and welcome
to the latest episode
oh the Boring Show.
MATT: Welcome.
EMILY: So we have a
number of questions
that people have been posting,
and so we wanted to address
a couple of those first.
MATT: Do they know who we are?
I guess we've been
on so many times.
I'm Matt.
EMILY: Hi, I'm Emily.
It's the Matt and Emily show.
What could possibly go wrong?
MATT: Are we building
a countdown app?
EMILY: In one hour.
MATT: OK, questions.
EMILY: Yes.
MATT: OK.
EMILY: All right,
so first, we get
people asking with
some frequency
where the code is located.
It's on Philip's GitHub.
It's Phillip H,
github.com/philiph,
and then hn_app app for
the Hacker News app.
People also keep
asking about when
is a Flutter channel happening.
It is happening soon.
This year.
MATT: Yes.
Keep your eyes open.
It will be happening
in the near future.
EMILY: Very soon.
Would you like to
take a question?
MATT: Sure, fire
a question at me.
EMILY: So Gill
McLorry asks about--
he wants to see more full-blown
e-commerce apps with Flutter.
MATT: OK.
So we have a couple
of sample apps,
I think in /flutter/samples.
One is Shrine 2.
Is Shrine 2 there?
I think so.
EMILY: I think so.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
MATT: OK.
EMILY: Yeah it is.
MATT: And that gives
an example of sort
of the basic framework for
having a collection of items
and adding it to
a shopping cart.
Doesn't necessarily do all the
checkout and payment pieces.
Philip also has his
state experiments,
demonstrated how to apply
different architectural styles
or different state management,
to a shopping cart sample.
So that might be useful.
And then I know recently
Square's released
their plug-ins for both physical
payments with the dongly
thing--
technical term, dongly thing--
and also their virtual
payments as well.
So there's a few resources
to get you started.
EMILY: Yeah, and I believe
Square has examples in there
plug-ins.
So you can check those out
for actually making payments.
MATT: Oh, and there's also
Andrew's Veggie Seasons
app, which isn't
necessarily e-commerce,
but does have the concepts
of different items
and showing them in
lists in an iOS style.
So that might be useful.
EMILY: Yeah.
So we're probably not going
to implement e-commerce
in our Hacker News app.
Unless we're charging--
MATT: We could sell dashes.
EMILY: We could get some
money to our failing
internet journalism economy,
charge for articles.
But yeah, maybe if we do
another app we'll work on that.
Prasad Pankar asks about00
oh, this was in, I think,
two episodes back.
Andrew was working
with the GDEs and they
had two buttons
in a row, and they
added a spacer between them.
And someone was asking,
oh, what about the space
between parameter when
you put things in a row?
Is that better, or
should you use padding,
or should you use spacer?
I would say I think it
depends on the situation.
So if you have just
two buttons, you
can stick a spacer in there.
Sure, whatever.
If you have maybe five
buttons or something,
putting a spacer widget
in between gets annoying.
And so I think that
space between parameter
would be perfect.
I think just kind
of look at your code
and see if it
starts looking busy.
MATT: And does spacer
do relative positioning
or actual positioning?
I haven't really used it.
EMILY: I don't know.
MATT: So space between
does relative positioning,
so irrespective of
size or whatnot,
it will space them
appropriately.
But if you really want
to tweak your spaces
and you want to have
that precise control,
then spacers or how you size
box a lot between things,
and there's padding as well.
So there's a bunch
of different ways
you can do spacing in Flutter.
And it really depends on
the situation and also
your preference.
EMILY: Yeah.
So I would say, in summary,
just try and look at the code
and see what looks cleanest.
That's kind of the main thing.
People also keep asking
about Google Maps in Flutter.
First of all, there
is a plug-in that's
created by the Flutter team
for Google Maps in Footer.
It is currently in
developer preview,
and we're working hard
on getting that out
of developer preview.
So expect a demo on
that soon as well.
MATT: Warning on--
you can use it now
and it works really well.
But that API will break.
EMILY: It will change.
MATT: Sorry.
EMILY: It will work right now.
MATT: It will work right
now, but the API will change
and thus will, if you
use the current API,
you will need to update
your code in the future,
because we're ensuring
that that API elegantly
fits with Flutter widget style.
So we're still iterating
on that to make
sure we give a, hopefully, what
we consider to be a really good
experience through the SDK.
So if you use it now,
bear in mind you're
going to be going back to
change your code somewhat
in the future when you
upgrade to the latest version.
EMILY: I will say, though,
thanks to pub specs
and versioning, if you leave it
at the version that you're at--
MATT: That's true.
EMILY: --it won't break.
So you could keep--
yeah, your code can
stay consistent,
but there will be a
new version coming.
And if you want the
latest and greatest,
it will change a little bit.
And let's do one last question.
MATT: OK, one last question.
EMILY: So Em Feinstein was
asking about view models
interventions.
If you want to--
He was saying he'd never heard
of view models in context
of Flutter.
And so where do you use
it and what does it--
MATT: View models is a
reasonably abstract concept.
And it can be applied to Flutter
or not applied to Flutter.
There is a good example
that I saw out there.
Somebody wrote an article
about using Flutter in Redux.
And what they did
was, after they
did the transform on
the store for the data,
they applied a view model
to make the data that didn't
necessarily fit elegantly
with how their widgets were
rendering, they transformed
it into a view model,
which then much more elegantly
fit how their UI looked.
So it was a nice way of
basically adapting your data so
that you didn't have
to do a lot of data
manipulation inside your code
for your widget tree itself.
So it wasn't necessary
by any means.
But for making your code maybe
that little bit more readable
or whatnot, it made sense.
If you've got simple
data, maybe it doesn't.
But if you've got a very
complex, mungy set of data
coming back from, whether
you're using a block in a stream
or you're using
scope model or Redux,
having to transform
that data into something
that fits your front end,
yeah, that would seem to work.
EMILY: Yeah.
The way I would think about
it is your view model--
so maybe you've got
this complex model
on the back end
of all this stuff,
and it's just the basic
concept of encapsulation.
So maybe you don't want
to expose all of that
to all of your widgets.
You only want to
expose a part of it.
So you put a little view--
it's just your API of what
you're showing to your widgets
to display.
To what Matt was
saying, I believe
that terminology is also used
in Brian Egan's Flutter Redux
package as well,
so check it out.
MATT: Yep.
EMILY: All right.
MATT: Good.
OK, so--
EMILY: Coding time.
MATT: Coding time.
What are we coding today?
What is the plan.
EMILY: So we're back
on the Hacker News app,
and the goal today is
accomplish two things.
MATT: Two things.
EMILY: So we're going
to show incorporating
web views into our
Hacker News app,
because when I'm
clicking through it,
it's kind of annoying that it
keeps opening into, say, Chrome
or whenever my
mobile browser is,
and I have to switch back
and forth from app to app.
So it would be nice to just
have a web view of that.
And then also people have been
asking about scroll position.
So we're going to--
so that when you switch between
the two tabs you can preserve
where you've scrolled .
So we will get into that too.
MATT: Sounds good.
EMILY: What could
possibly go wrong?
MATT: You're going to find out.
OK, so how are we
going to kick off?
What's the first thing
we're going to do.
EMILY: Well, would
you like to code?
MATT: I guess I would.
I love to code.
You know me.
I might even balance my
brackets correctly this time.
Wouldn't that be adorable?
OK, so what have we got here?
We've got the Hacker
News app running,
and I've got it in
my iOS simulator.
And when I click on
one of these, I can--
boink-- and so this is
taking me out to probably
Safari's version of a
non-address-viewable--
what's it when you don't
have the address bar?
An address bar-less Safari view.
Wow, that took a lot more
effort than it should have done.
And so I can see
it and that's fine.
And I can go back
and I have done,
but that's not
using the web view.
EMILY: And that's actually--
I will say, so I was
plunking around with Android
and that experience
is better on iOS.
MATT: So there's a trick
to hiding the thing.
So let's take a look.
In here, we have--
here we go.
So this here, we're using
the URL launch package.
EMILY: Yep.
MATT: And here is where--
let me get rid of this.
There we go.
Here is where
we're launching it.
So what you can do, if you take
a look, is this actually has--
if I have autocomplete working--
it has force Safari web view.
EMILY: Mm-hmm.
MATT: And it also has--
whoops-- it has force web view.
So let's just take
a look at the--
let's take a look at these.
So force Safari
web you is for iOS.
And this will either launch
Safari in full-blown Safari
or not--
and we can play around
with that in a second--
and this force web view does
the same thing for Android.
So you can get it to hide.
So if I come in here and
I went force Safari VC,
let's make that true, save.
Let's see do I
need to hard reload
or do we need to
do a full restart?
OK, so that's probably
the way it normally is.
OK, that's fine.
Let's make it false and
we'll do the same thing.
We have to do a hard
restart on that one.
So let's hard restart
this and take a look.
This is how we're
starting, here we go.
That's the same as before.
This is where it's
going to embarrass me
by doing the same thing
every single time.
[LAUGHTER]
EMILY: If that's true, we're
going to expect to [INAUDIBLE]..
MATT: I'm hoping it's going
to be like, big reveal.
There's this there something.
OK, well, not really.
What that lets you play with,
again, going back to it,
is this opens web URLs in
Safari container versus view
controller versus
full-screen Safari.
That's what should happen.
But at the moment, it doesn't
seem to quite be doing that.
So if you want--
EMILY: Do you think
it's something
because we're using an emulator?
MATT: Oh, it might be.
But if you want to do that on--
EMILY: Would you want to--
I don't know if you want
to pull up a Android.
Actually, you keep talking.
I'm going to pull up--
try and do it on the
Android and see if I--
MATT: Well, let's see if we
can get it working in Android.
So let Emily pull
up hers, and we
were going to jump
into web views,
but we'll stick with URL
launch for the time being.
EMILY: No, you can keep
going onto web views.
I'm just going to play around
with this, because I'm curious
what we're supposed to see.
MATT: So try force web view and
see what you get on that side.
Right, I'm going to keep
going on the web view.
So what we want
to do is, instead
of having the full
screen view controller,
we want to be able to
use a widget, a web view
widget, which will allow
us to embed the panel,
or the widget that's showing--
or create a widget that will
let us see the full web view.
And then that-- for a
full screen thing you'd
ask why we'd want to do that.
Well, it will let us
do a bunch of things.
Predominantly, we can
treat it as a widget
and we can put other
widgets in the page.
We can overlay
widgets on top of it.
So let's take a look at
what we want to do there.
The first thing we want to do is
we need to include the package.
So the package for web view
is, we're going to go in here.
And let's go over to--
EMILY: See here?
Sorry.
When I do it on Android, it
asks which browser do you
want to open it on?
And so then I'm like, let's
say just once, but then--
OK, thank you, Chrome.
No!
OK, so you got this.
But--
MATT: So you've got full-blown
Chrome at that point.
EMILY: Yeah, but then you
have to literally swap.
I haven't added your
thing, but that's
why I was like, that's why you
actually want to add webview.
I'm not--
MATT: That's also true.
EMILY: I'm not sure why on iOS
it's just already more awesome.
MATT: No comment.
[LAUGHTER]
EMILY: OK, sorry, please.
I'm going to try this
forced web view thing.
MATT: OK.
What was I doing?
I was going to Flutter packages,
and I am going to pull up our--
EMILY: The web view package.
MATT: The web view package.
EMILY: And I think it's called--
MATT: Flutter a view.
No, it's not that one.
EMILY: So here's a
little trick thing.
There are two web view packages.
There's a community
one and then the one
that is provided by
the Flutter team.
And I believe that the
community one is actually
planning on redirecting to the
main one once the main one is--
this is also in developer
preview, I will say,
but it's pretty darn stable.
And the Flutter team one
has a couple other features
that we can get into later that
the community one does not yet.
MATT: Absolutely.
So the one we're looking
for is the web view Flutter.
And obviously, we're
fairly far down
the versioning at
the moment, 0.1.2,
but we're going to use this one.
So I'm going to take
webview_Flutter,
going to go back
to my dependencies,
and I don't need that.
Let's pop it in here.
And I am going to
put in the version,
and then that's going to go
and pull down a bunch of stuff.
So there we go.
So I'm going to go
back to my code.
And what I'm going to do--
so we have the launch here.
So what I'm going to do is let
me create a new widget that's
going to represent the new
page that we're going to go to.
So I'm going to go
all the way to go--
OK, so let's just
go to the bottom.
And I am going to create
a stateless widget,
and I'm going to call this--
EMILY: Full page web view.
MATT: Full page--
EMILY: How does that--
MATT: Hacker News page--
Hacker News--
EMILY: Article.
MATT: Oh, you know, OK,
I'm going to call it
Hacker News web page.
That's a terrible name.
I'll change it in a second.
So what I'm going to do here
is, I'm going to do the usual.
I'm going to need a
scaffold because I'm
going to a new page.
I don't need a
scaffold, but I'm going
to use a scaffold, because
it's going to make things nice.
EMILY: For the record--
sorry, this forced web view,
I'm not seeing any difference.
MATT: Really?
Because I played
around with it before.
And it would give
you, basically,
a full-blown web browser.
It would hide the address bar.
EMILY: That thing?
MATT: Yeah.
EMILY: Huh.
MATT: The interface has changed
in that, or maybe I was--
I-- maybe--
EMILY: I don't know.
MATT: It's like that.
EMILY: Sorry.
MATT: No worries.
EMILY: Continue.
MATT: OK, so what am I doing?
I'm adding an app bar.
Isn't that exciting?
Now we're just
going to call this--
let's just title
this up, uh, just
call it web page for the moment.
Of course that needs
to be a widget.
OK, there we go.
So that's good.
So now in the body of this,
what we're going to put in
is-- well, what do we have now?
So we have--
I bet we have something
like this, which
means that I can go in and--
EMILY: Is it-- did
you do packages get?
MATT: I did do packages get.
Let's just double check
the name of this--
EMILY: [INAUDIBLE]
looks like it's red.
Is that normal?
MATT: Yeah.
I do the fancy material.
EMILY: Did you import it?
MATT: I'm trying to get it to
import, but unfortunately--
EMILY: Oh, the auto import.
MATT: Auto import's not working.
So import package, Websocket
channel is not what I want.
EMILY: That'd be Flutter.
MATT: Flutter.
EMILY: There you go.
MATT: And we're going to come
down here and, OK, great.
So we have a web view.
So what does a web view take?
Well, web view takes
a bunch of things.
But there's a nice
handy initial URL.
Initial URL, and that's
going to take, let's just--
EMILY: Oh, it's just
a straight, it's
not a-- it's just parameter.
MATT: Oh, it's parameter.
Not enough coffee in the world.
Let's take that out of it.
So this is going
to build a page.
It's going to have a web bar
and it's going to have web view.
EMILY: Very exciting.
MATT: Super exciting.
Let's modify it a
bit and call this--
Philip's totally going
to rename it something.
EMILY: That's what
[INAUDIBLE] for.
MATT: Exactly.
Next time, fix Matt's
terrible naming system.
I'm going to pass the URL--
final string URL-- and
we can make use of that
once we have that going.
So let's go back to launcher.
And so what we want to do here
now is, we have the result
and can launch, so let's
just take this out of time.
What we're going to
do is we are here,
we've got our [INAUDIBLE]
pressed, we've got our result.
So if our result is
not equal to null,
then we are going
to push a new page.
So we are going to do--
EMILY: Material page route--
or navigator.push.
MATT: Navigator.push.
So we've got to get
navigator.of from our context,
if I remember correctly.
EMILY: Actually, fun fact,
you can do navigator.push
and pass in context,
or navigator.of context
and then push.
MATT: All right, let's try that.
So let's do navigator.push.
Never tried this.
Cool.
And so you say we can
probably take context.
That actually makes it
look a little tidier.
EMILY: Yeah, I feel
like just fewer things.
I think it's just a--
it's not a named parameter.
MATT: Oh, it isn't?
EMILY: It's like [INAUDIBLE].
I guess they didn't do that.
MATT: And then
we're going to have
to have a material page root.
Material page root takes a--
EMILY: Builder.
MATT: Builder.
OK.
EMILY: That takes
a context, I think.
MATT: That takes a
builder, which takes a--
EMILY: Little context.
And then--
MATT: Context, which then is
going to return a-- and we
called it--
sorry, I called it--
Hacker News, best web
page ever, longest name.
And we couldn't go result dot--
is the URL in here somewhere?
I think there is--
URL, comma--
EMILY: Dun dun dun.
MATT: And it-- wait, not comma.
There you go, that
looks slightly nicer.
OK, so let's go down
the bottom and let's
actually use that URL because I
don't think we need to do this,
because clearly code
works first time.
OK, so we've got this.
I'm going to do a hard
restart, just 'cause.
I munch about the roots,
probably not necessary.
That's going to
go pull this down.
Start with a website,
not a mobile app.
Well, let's pick
up the next one.
[LAUGHTER]
EMILY: How appropriate?
MATT: And then when we
click on this, it does that.
EMILY: What what?
MATT: What what?
Yeah, what, what exactly.
EMILY: That's not a nav bar.
MATT: Wait a second.
That's-- I commented out.
EMILY: Yeah.
MATT: Launch.
Is that why my thing
wasn't working properly?
Oh, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait.
EMILY: What?
MATT: Oh, that's
from the icon button.
What did I change?
Two places.
EMILY: Oh jeez.
Maybe I was in the
wrong place too.
MATT: This tile text--
where is this?
Oh, this is the-- am I
in the wrong list view?
Because there's two list views.
EMILY: No results.
Oh my gosh.
MATT: This is from
new stories, I bet.
Is it?
EMILY: I thought
we had just one--
MATT: It's the same one.
OK.
EMILY: This suggests
it's time for a refactor.
MATT: I'm going to go and
I'm going to cut and paste
my code to that other place.
EMILY: I'm going to
look up and figure out
why we have two launches.
MATT: OK.
All right, so I'm
going to take this
and then I am going
to go find here,
icons.launch, and so we're going
to take this individual out
and we're going to pop this in.
We don't need our if
statement anymore.
EMILY: There is a build results
method that is not called.
MATT: OK, refactor time.
And here we have article.URL.
Let's save that.
EMILY: This is why we
should have code reviews.
MATT: This is why I should
have read the code before I
started writing this.
EMILY: Both of us.
MATT: OK, so let's
see what happens now.
And I go here and, oh, look,
I have a platform exception.
I'm trying to
create a [INAUDIBLE]
an unregistered type.
Aha.
So, the first thing
that we should note
is there's an extra step that
you need to take at the moment
when you're doing iOS with
web use and not Android.
And if you're not like me
and actually read the readme,
it says--
EMILY: I didn't read the readme.
MATT: --we need to put
into the p info list--
it would have been handy
if we just actually
had the XML that I
could cut and paste in.
EMILY: Yeah.
I actually--
MATT: That's fine.
We can-- that's easy.
So what I need to do is
I need to go into here
and do some munging.
We'll just let that crash out.
Oh, it's a web page.
EMILY: But there's no--
MATT: Yeah, no, it's
because the system
itself barfed at that point
because I unpaused the thing.
So where are we?
EMILY: Oh, because it crashed.
MATT: Yeah.
EMILY: Got it.
MATT: We are runner--
EMILY: Yeah.
So we're going-- this
is a step only for iOS
because Android doesn't
have the view listing.
And again, this should
go away when we're
outside of developer preview.
MATT: Yeah so I'm
going to need a key,
and my key is going to be this.
EMILY: I have my Flutter
[INAUDIBLE] views preview.
MATT: And we're going to
have, if I remember correctly,
a string.
EMILY: If you curate, yeah.
I'm pretty sure I did that.
MATT: Today on the Boring
Show, we write XML.
EMILY: Matt's favorite.
MATT: Yes, it is.
[LAUGHTER]
I love XML.
I'm crying on the inside.
EMILY: Send Matt all
your XML questions.
He'll gladly answer them.
MATT: Please don't.
I don't know if that should
be capitalized or not.
We'll find out.
EMILY: It's all caps,
I'm pretty sure.
MATT: So because
I've changed my iOS,
I'm going to rebuild everything.
EMILY: Yeah.
MATT: Because what
you change on that,
it's not going to pick
it up because we're going
to have to rebuild in effect.
EMILY: We're outside
of the Flutter world,
so hot reload, all bets are off.
MATT: And I'm going to
just be on the safe side
and I'm going to wipe
out my build because--
EMILY: I don't normally do it.
MATT: I've been bitten
by that once or twice.
And I'm going to
start running again.
OK.
EMILY: Did you delete
the other method?
MATT: Did I delete-- which one?
EMILY: Sorry, the one that was--
build results or
something that--
yeah, build results.
You can delete that
as far as I can tell.
MATT: I'll delete it
once I see it working.
And then if it stops working
[INAUDIBLE] deleted it.
Can you tell I'm
slightly paranoid?
OK, so this is going to take
a few seconds to fire up.
I'm going to take a look
at that URL launcher thing
after the show.
And the next time we have a
show, we're going to clarify.
EMILY: I suspect it might be
because we were both changing
it in the wrong function.
MATT: We were changing it in
the wrong function, that's
very true.
But I'm not going to go back
and waste another 15 minutes.
EMILY: No, agreed.
I don't think--
we're not going to--
MATT: OK.
EMILY: Yay!
MATT: There we go.
Never been so excited about
bringing up a web page.
That's good.
OK, look, it does the
scrolly scrolly thing.
It does the navigation
navigation thing.
EMILY: Oh, so I think
you should show them
one other little quick thing.
So this is just like
any other widget.
So you can stick
other Flutter widgets
on top of it or something.
You want to just like throw
in a floating action bar,
just for fun?
MATT: I'm just going to throw
in a floating action bar button.
I can throw in a
floating action--
action bar.
[LAUGHTER]
EMILY: It can be useless.
MATT: Like I said, not
enough coffee in the world.
EMILY: Just to prove
that it's a widget.
MATT: This is nice, because
I've created a new widget,
so I can do what
I like down here.
So I'm going to, in effect, I
can probably stay on that page.
EMILY: Yeah.
MATT: So let's just
fire up that page again.
EMILY: Hot reload for the win.
MATT: This should
be a different page,
but yeah, it's
doing webby things.
EMILY: Would now be a good
time to talk about JavaScript?
So with web view you can
activate or deactivate--
or enable JavaScript.
MATT: You can see your
JavaScript mode is currently
disabled.
EMILY: Yes, so by
default it's disabled.
And I got an email from Amir,
who created the web view
plug-in literally last
night, and there's
going to be breaking change
with the name of that variable.
It's going to be lowercase
s, so JavaScript mode.
But right now--
MATT: We have a typo to fix.
So yes, your idea will hopefully
give you the right thing.
EMILY: It should
be pretty close.
You can figure it out.
MATT: What is this going to do?
Is this going to be--
EMILY: It's ena--
MATT: JavaScript mode.enabled.
And I'm assuming he's
going to fix that--
EMILY: Unrestricted.
MATT: So that'll probably
change as well, then.
EMILY: Yeah.
MATT: OK, so let's save that up.
I'll probably need
to re-navigate.
Yay.
Now I'm just unrestricted
run JavaScript.
Nothing can go wrong.
EMILY: Right?
MATT: What was I doing?
You wanted a
floating action bar.
I'm going to go--
stateless [INAUDIBLE]
widget, floating action bar.
EMILY: Oh, just
stick it in this--
MATT: It's a joke.
It's a joke.
We're just going to write
a floating action button.
It's going to float, do actions.
It's going to be great.
EMILY: Do it.
MATT: All right, I'm just
going to put a floating action
button in here.
Floating action
button takes a child.
EMILY: Yeah.
MATT: And that's
going to be an icon.
Like this.
EMILY: Sure.
Yeah.
MATT: And this is going to be--
EMILY: I think there's
a icons.favorite.
Yeah.
Heart.
MATT: Icons.favorite.
EMILY: I think it'll appear
even if we don't have it--
MATT: Oh look.
EMILY: Look at that.
So yeah, right now pressing
it doesn't do anything.
But this is just to
prove that you can
stack any other thing on it.
MATT: Well, look.
It's just like-- it's
got a little shadow there
because I put the unpressed in.
And we can put other things.
Like, basically, this
is just a widget.
EMILY: Yeah.
But right now I think
it's probably not useful.
So we can take it out.
MATT: This is
probably not useful.
So we will take it out.
And there we go.
Got it.
So this is nice, but this is
fairly coarse-grained, just
full web page view.
So wouldn't it be nice if we
had a preview screen, perhaps?
EMILY: That would be nice.
Maybe I could implement it.
MATT: Maybe you
could implement it.
Do you want me to push
this, or should we just--
OK, I'll push this change.
EMILY: Or I mean, actually--
I could just go.
MATT: I'm going to push--
EMILY: No, you push so I'll
have the imports and everything.
MATT: Oh yeah, you can
have all the imports.
Also Phillip will
start weeping when
he sees Hacker News web
page, the page, you know,
app suddenly appear.
So where am I?
Master plus four.
Why don't you talk a
little bit about what
you're going to do while
I do boring push things.
EMILY: Yes, so I will
make a little preview,
because I don't
know, sometimes I
read the links on
the Hacker News app
and I'm like, what is that?
Do I want to click
on it to read more?
I don't know.
So we can put a little
web view to see if we
want to read the full thing.
And so this is probably not
the best use of web view,
but I just want to show it
to show another way of how
you can corporate web use into
the rest of your Flutter app.
And there's a interesting
thing that's going to happen.
So the list view is scrollable,
and your web view is also
scrollable, but you want to be
able to scroll that little web
view preview when
you are also doing--
so that you can
preview that page.
So there's a
parameter on web view
that's like a
gesture recognizer.
And you can use it to capture
any gestures for that web view.
For example, if I scroll
in the web view part,
it'll scroll that, but if I
scroll outside the web view,
then I can scroll the
whole list view itself.
You can do that with
any gesture you want.
The other thing to keep
in mind with web views
is if you have multiple web
views, like in this case where
I might have a web view
for every single article
when I expand that tile, you--
have you pushed?
MATT: Yes.
EMILY: All right.
We'll talk about keys--
well, multiple web views--
in a minute.
All right.
Let me pull [INAUDIBLE].
MATT: Uh oh.
EMILY: It's because
I deleted that--
it's because I
deleted that function,
the unnecessary function.
MATT: Now you can go on
like that [INAUDIBLE]..
EMILY: Get [INAUDIBLE].
All right, and let us--
MATT: Your get-fu is far, far,
far in advance of my get-fu.
EMILY: It's because I have
gotten in so many weird spots.
MATT: That's because I'm
always like, I'm just
going to push first.
EMILY: Flutter packages
get, just to get everything.
MATT: Yep.
EMILY: All right.
So let me launch this.
MATT: So you're-- OK,
so you're using Android,
which we don't need to change
any of the Android manifest
files or anything like that.
EMILY: Correct.
MATT: It should just work.
EMILY: But even if we--
well, if I was using
iOS, because you
had changed [INAUDIBLE]
pull your code down,
it would have it.
MATT: Yes, if you
were using iOS.
EMILY: But anyway.
Yes, so what we want
to do is we want to,
in our little-- let's find
the expanded tile widget that
allows you to click, and then
go to see that new launch thing.
So expanded--
expansion tile, my bad.
All right, so I'm going to
get rid of commented code
because it's just
taking up space.
MATT: Who needs comments?
[LAUGHTER]
EMILY: Commented out code.
Comments are good.
The code's like, not executing.
What's that for?
Why is it not launching?
This is like--
MATT: I don't know.
Are we having--
EMILY: Flashbacks of
Flutter Live here?
MATT: ADB problems.
No, you're good, you're good.
EMILY: OK.
While it continues to
think about launching,
so we've got this
on-pressed function
and we have our
comments, got our button.
MATT: So there is
an icon button.
EMILY: So we
probably-- let's see.
This is all in a row.
How about we wrap it in a column
and then we can stick the web
view below that?
MATT: Yeah, that makes sense.
That sounds good.
EMILY: What the heck?
It's not launching again.
MATT: Is there a--
EMILY: My computer--
MATT: What does your
debug console say?
Oh, articles search
extends, build results--
oh, it is using build results.
EMILY: Oh.
My bad.
MATT: Use dash.
Good news is we already
updated the code for that.
EMILY: Yeah.
MATT: What is that doing?
Oh, that's where we do
the search thing here.
EMILY: I'm going to
do a get reset hard.
MATT: So let's take a look.
Did that actually work, while
Emily is fixing that, back over
to me.
So this is probably
happening here.
So we've got a search.
So I can type in cre
and that would appear.
And then when I click on, yeah.
So that takes it to--
so that's using the--
EMILY: So then do we
need it technically
implement it in both?
The launch thing?
I mean, we can do that later.
MATT: I think we
should dry up our code.
EMILY: Dry up our code?
MATT: Dry-- only write it once?
What is the--
EMILY: Oh, don't
repeat yourself.
MATT: Don't repeat yourself.
I just repeated you.
Don't repeat Emily.
Dre.
[LAUGHTER]
It's a thing.
D-R-E, I just invented it.
That's me.
So yeah, we should probably--
EMILY: Or actually do
repeat Emily for emphasis.
MATT: Do repeat Emily.
So yeah, OK, that's
used on the search page.
So that's that mystery solved.
EMILY: Although I feel like,
yes, as you were saying,
we should factor
things out because it
seems like a shared code.
MATT: Yep.
EMILY: We can deal with
that in a little bit
because right now we're
talking about web views.
MATT: OK, so we're going to
update the expanded place.
Oh no, we're building still.
EMILY: Assuming--
MATT: We're building.
Here we go.
We're building.
Something's running.
EMILY: Oh my god.
MATT: The anticipation.
EMILY: You would think
this was a complicated--
MATT: I know.
EMILY: --compute-intensive app.
MATT: Pushing all them code--
EMILY: Yeah, OK, phew.
All right, so here we go.
So as we were talking about,
let us wrap this in a column.
MATT: OK.
I think Flutter
coding just always
comes down to wrapping columns
and rows and vise versa.
EMILY: Yes.
Oh, and people asked
about this a lot.
They're like, how did you get
that little pull down thing?
On a Mac, it's Command period,
and on Linux or Windows
it is Control
period, pretty sure.
And this is in VS Code.
MATT: Yes, in VS Code.
I can't remember what
it is in Android Studio.
EMILY: It's, I think, Alt Enter
or something, Option Enter.
MATT: So two ones you need to
know for Visual Studio Code is
Command dot for that, and if you
want to get the context menu,
it's Command Control P.
EMILY: Yes.
MATT: Which gives you the full
list of things you can do.
It's how I do a hard
restart, anyway.
EMILY: Why does it not like--
oh, just because--
OK.
So initial URL is going to be
the URL of this thing, which
is--
MATT: So we have article.url.
EMILY: Oh, article.
OK.
[INAUDIBLE]
MATT: Cool.
EMILY: Why is it
not happy with me?
MATT: Positional arguments.
EMILY: Oh, we're not
in the children's list.
That would be--
There we go.
MATT: There we go.
EMILY: OK, so there's that.
MATT: Mm-hmm.
EMILY: Now this is
going to be huge.
MATT: Just going
to put this in a--
EMILY: So maybe we'll--
MATT: Whoa.
EMILY: Oh, and it's
unhappy because it expands
to fit the size, but list view
is a infinitely expandable
thing.
So it's like, oh my gosh,
I can expand everywhere.
So let's wrap it in a container.
MATT: Container?
Cool.
EMILY: And give it a size.
MATT: So we don't need to
give it a height, right?
Because it'll fit the width.
EMILY: Yeah, it'll expand
for the rest of it.
OK, that's a little better,
except I'm not-- oh,
there we go.
MATT: Oh, that's nice.
That's looking good.
EMILY: We should probably enable
the JavaScript thing again.
MATT: We should
enable JavaScript.
EMILY: JavaScript
mode unrestricted.
And this clearly functions
without JavaScript.
Whoa, that was fun.
Method--
MATT: Get size on a
null object reference.
EMILY: Something in Android.
I'm gonna copy this, and I
might send Amir a bug report.
I've not seen this, but--
MATT: Yeah.
When in doubt,
file a bug report.
Start it up again.
But cool.
So as you can see,
with a web view,
it is just another widget.
So you can resize it,
you can draw over it,
you can put in a stack
and do crazy things.
You can probably animate
it around the place,
if you're feeling
particularly creative,
is one way of putting it.
But yeah, you can--
EMILY: You want to give
designers headaches.
MATT: You can have
expand-o-vision
on your web page.
So it's as flexible
as you want it to be.
Now, because this is using--
this is being rendered
by the underlying
either Android or iOS system.
And it's using our new platform
widget, I believe it's called.
EMILY: Mm-hmm.
MATT: Which is a way
that you can actually
take Android views or
the equivalent in iOS
and have them render
through our widget piece.
It's not free.
There's a little bit of cost,
in terms of performance when
you have one or two on screen.
Probably not
noticeable, but just
be aware that if you use
these types of widgets that
are rendered by the
platform, the more you add,
the greater the cost
you're going to incur.
So just handy tip there.
Use these--
EMILY: Judiciously.
MATT: I was going
to say sparingly.
Judiciously is two
more syllables.
That sounds much
more impressive.
So-- what she said.
[LAUGHTER]
EMILY: OK.
MATT: Don't repeat Emily.
EMILY: Dre.
[LAUGHTER]
All right, so--
MATT: Does it work again?
EMILY: It is.
MATT: OK.
EMILY: So it works.
And now the one other thing is,
so you can see I'm scrolling--
list view scrolls.
But I can't scroll
this web view.
So right now it's just like,
oh, well I can see the title,
but maybe I want just
a little bit more.
So you can use this
gesture recognizer
to capture some
gestures that you want.
So it's just a parameter.
It takes a set.
And so I'm going
to add to that set.
MATT: Oh, you're doing that
double double dot thing,
which is really-- what
do they call that?
EMILY: Um--
MATT: There's a term.
It's the double
dot thing, and it's
a really handy way of keeping
your code neat and clean.
EMILY: Yeah, basically it's
returning the original calling
object.
So it'll return the set.
So rather than using a
set declaring a variable
and then adding it, I'm
just like, take the set
and I'm adding to it.
But add-- I think
it returns void,
but we want to return the set.
Anyway, OK, so we're adding--
just a recognizer is a--
my computer is
trying to calculate--
MATT: Pi for some reason.
EMILY: Yeah.
I seem to have lost
the ability to--
oh my gosh.
MATT: Why don't you right
click and read the--
EMILY: Yeah.
So OK.
So we want a factor--
yes, I'm going to jump to
the definition because--
MATT: No, not functions,
command [INAUDIBLE]..
Oh, no we weren't.
EMILY: Function F12,
jumps to definition.
MATT: Does function
F12 jump to definition?
OK.
I should be taking notes.
EMILY: Yeah.
Not function-- yeah.
OK, so just the recognizer.
So we need a factory of--
MATT: I'm scared by this one
sequence gesture recognizer
giant thing.
Is it scary?
EMILY: No.
MATT: OK.
EMILY: It's just a
typedef, if I recall.
So my computer, I don't
know what's going on.
MATT: Not enough cores.
More cores.
EMILY: Except this is
like a brand new computer.
Come on, guys all right, so we
have a factory and apparently
we no longer have--
there we go.
Syntax dialogue.
MATT: I'd suggest you
run top, but we don't
want to be debugging your--
EMILY: Let me-- I'm
going to kill Chrome.
Start with that.
MATT: When in
doubt, kill Chrome.
[LAUGHTER]
EMILY: OK, so we want
to make a factory.
MATT: So what does it look
like in the actual code itself?
EMILY: If I can get
back to that page.
Oh my gosh.
MATT: OK, why don't you--
EMILY: Commit and--
MATT: I'm going to take a
look at-- what's it called?
EMILY: Factory.
Yeah, so just the recognizers.
MATT: OK.
So while Emily fixes her piece--
EMILY: While my
computer decides to--
MATT: I'm going to go
and find my web view.
EMILY: How about--
MATT: And we're going to take
a quick look at the code for--
EMILY: Maybe I've been banned
from using my computer.
MATT: OK, no worries.
We'll take a look through mine.
So I'm going to go here.
I'm going to take a look
at gesture recognizers.
And as we see here, this
is going to take a set,
but what we really want
to do is we want to go
and we want to check out--
whoops.
[INAUDIBLE]
I need to function F12.
EMILY: I'm going to commit this.
And I think we're going
to go to your computer,
because my computer is--
MATT: OK.
So what we have here is
we have a set factory
of one sequence gesture
recognizer, gesture recognizer.
Now the one sequence gesture
recognizer, abstract class.
And takes a whole
bunch of things.
And so we're going to
need a factory to create
a set of gestures, I assume.
So what were you doing here?
You were doing dot
dot add inside here.
We're going to need
to create a factory.
I'm going to wait for Emily,
because she knows more
about this than I
do, and of course I
may be stumbling in the
dark for creating these.
EMILY: Oh my gosh.
MATT: So the nice
thing is that you
are able to capture
any type of gestures.
So you can capture
scrolly gestures
or tap gestures or zoomy--
any-- I believe any type of
gestures that Flutter supports.
EMILY: Yes, scrolly, zoomy.
MATT: Wow, OK.
What we're going
to do here is we're
going to take a
slight break and we're
going to come back
in a minute or two,
because I think we're
going to resolve
a couple of technical
difficulties
before we continue.
So back in a second.
[BEEPING]
And we're back.
EMILY: Hello.
I have a different computer now.
MATT: I've got a computer
what doesn't work anymore.
Thanks, Emily.
EMILY: All right, so back
to gesture recognizers,
we're going to add a
factory of the gestures
that we want to capture.
MATT: A factory of
the gesture, OK.
EMILY: So the reason
is because, again,
if you hop over here to
see, gesture recognizers
takes a factory of these
gesture recognizers.
So we are making a gesture
recognizer, if you will.
MATT: OK.
EMILY: So let me hop into
factory for a hot second.
It's just a generic thing.
So we want a vertical
scrolling gesture recognized.
So let's make--
MATT: So we don't
want to capture
any gestures other than
just the vertical scrolling.
EMILY: Yes.
And I think-- let me look
up the name of this thing.
MATT: Vertical here.
There is a T missing.
EMILY: Oh, that would help.
One sequence gesture recognizer.
MATT: Mm-hmm.
EMILY: That-- can we
pull up what all--
MATT: Web view web browser?
EMILY: Yes.
One sequence gesture recognizer.
In a different thing.
We want this on Flutter.
MATT: Tab Gesture recognizer.
Gesture recognizer.
EMILY: OK, so we want--
MATT: A one sequence
gesture recognizer?
EMILY: Yes.
And it's not-- it's a drag,
and it's vertical drag gesture
recognizer.
MATT: There we go.
OK.
This all looks super
complicated, but--
EMILY: Just read the dots.
MATT: The code itself,
read the example.
EMILY: Vertical drag--
I can't remember this.
Oh, drag, no.
MATT: Vertical drag--
EMILY: Vertical drag gesture.
Gesture recognizer.
MATT: Yay.
We probably have to
import something, right?
EMILY: Probably.
MATT: Actually dynamic.
Oh, do we have to do some
sort of initialization
on the factory?
EMILY: Yeah, I think it's
like a .create or something.
Factory.construct on the type.
MATT: You've got the type.
EMILY: This is a
set of factories.
So--
MATT: It's the problem
of saying it's trying
to return factory dynamic.
That isn't an expected type.
The constructor returns--
factory dynamic constructor--
Oh, because it's not finding it.
EMILY: It's not imported.
MATT: Yeah.
EMILY: OK, so again,
oops-- not that.
Import.
Whew.
MATT: Yay.
EMILY: OK.
And one required argument.
What is required for a factory?
Oh, it's a function
that returns.
So this is like a return
the vertical drag gesture
recognizer--
mouthful.
So--
MATT: OK.
EMILY: Vertical drag
gesture recognizer.
Let's see how this works.
MATT: So it gives
it a factory so it
can create the vertical drag--
EMILY: Yeah, and the factory--
MATT: --can make it.
OK.
EMILY: --is just like a little.
MATT: Now I understand
why it's doing that.
EMILY: Factory is basically
a glorified closure,
as far as I can tell.
It is a glorified closure.
MATT: Factories are
glorified closures.
OK.
EMILY: OK, so we have this.
And look.
MATT: Look at the scrolls.
It's got a scroll
bar and everything.
EMILY: And then you
can scroll this.
MATT: That's cool.
So now we--
OK, and we could do like
horizontal scrolling
if the window's too small.
EMILY: We can do the--
MATT: We could capture taps.
Because you probably can't
tap on a link in that, right?
Would we need to capture that?
EMILY: That's a good question.
Yeah.
MATT: OK.
So you have very fine-grained
control over this.
EMILY: Mm-hmm, yeah.
So f can capture
exactly what you want.
And I want to talk for just
a quick second about keys.
So we have, in this
thing, we're going
to have multiple web views.
MATT: Yes.
EMILY: Now, we already have
a key in here, up on this
build item with
this expansion tile,
so that when you
swap between these,
it knows to close the top two.
Basically, Flutter looks
at it as layout by type.
And so right now we have this
list view with expansion tiles,
and it just sees a list
of expansion tiles.
It doesn't know
anything about them.
And because the expansion
tiles have state,
like is it closed or is
opened, when we go over here,
these are new
expansion tiles and we
don't want them to be opened
because they're different.
And so we put it in
as this key thing.
MATT: There is a very
good video explaining
all of these key things
starring a certain cohost, which
I watched again last night to
remind myself exactly how keys
work, and this is pretty good.
So what is it?
Which--
EMILY: It's Widgets
101 and it's episode 4.
MATT: There you go.
Watch that one and
you will know all you
need to know about keys.
EMILY: And then some.
MATT: And then some.
EMILY: But so we
already have a key here,
but I want to show
another reason why,
if you have multiple web views
and you have this thing where
you have a list of web views,
keys might be necessary.
So I'm going to take it out.
And so let us--
we've got this--
MATT: 20% off our
search engine plans.
EMILY: Oh boy.
MATT: 20% off our
search engine plan.
EMILY: And yet we're
in a different tab.
And so because web
views are also stateful,
this is where you would
need to check out keys,
because it's like, oh, I have
a web view in this layout.
I'll just show it again.
Because it's trying to
optimize and be super fast
in performance.
So we put a key in to be
like, no, actually it's
a different web view.
MATT: So you're saying that
stateful widgets in something
like a list view, you
need to be careful
if you change the
things in the list,
because they may not update
without actually specifying
a key.
EMILY: Right.
And so this is a little funky.
Because like it
doesn't actually seem
like we're changing anything,
because it's like, oh,
I'm just scrolling
through the thing.
Under the covers, the
way we implemented it,
if you remember with Block
and stuff, we have a stream.
And we are simply changing
the different set of articles
that we display, be it top
stories or new stories.
So we are modifying
that list view.
MATT: So this is
the same list view
but it's showing
different lists.
EMILY: Yes.
MATT: OK.
EMILY: Yeah, so that's
why it gets a little--
we are modifying things
and keys become important.
OK, so we also promised that
we were going to show you page
view, but I feel like because
my computer cannot handle adding
web views, we took
a little more time.
So I'm going to give you a
quick preview of how to do that.
And then we can work through
that in a later episode.
So here's how it goes.
There is this other key
called a page storage
key that, incidentally,
stores the location of where
you are scrolling.
So what we would need to do is
we would go to our list view,
wherever that is.
List view, I think
this is the right one.
Build suggestions.
MATT: Oh, that suggestion,
that's the search one.
EMILY: OK.
OK, so, yes.
So what we would do is
you just take a key,
and it's page storage key.
MATT: OK.
EMILY: And you put in
a value that's unique.
However, if you remember
what I just said
a second ago about
streams, how actually,
in this case we
have one list view
and we're just kind
of swapping out--
MATT: We have one list view,
but showing two different lists.
EMILY: Yes.
MATT: Depending on
what you have-- yes.
EMILY: So if we
try and store where
we've scrolled in the single
list view and then change it,
it's going to get
really mad at us.
It's going to be
like, wait, what?
I was scrolled here
and now suddenly I'm
scrolled in this other place.
And so it's going to yell at us.
So the solution is-- and this is
why we're not going to do this
right now--
is we can use a--
I think it's a--
we can break out the
stream into two streams.
So we have the top stories
and the new stories.
And then we will put it in
actually two separate tabs
instead of this list view
thing that pretends to--
that's adding and removing.
MATT: And so what
happens then is
when you switch
between the two tabs--
EMILY: It will store.
MATT: Your lists will be stored
at the appropriate scroll
points for both of them.
EMILY: Yes.
So you can look forward to
that in this upcoming episode.
MATT: And we'll be sure to
use my computer for that.
EMILY: Yeah.
I think I've been
banned from ever--
MATT: Your fan is like--
this is actually quite toasty.
I'm warm now.
EMILY: So thanks for watching.
Feel free to throw in any
more comments or questions
down in the comments,
and we will be back in--
MATT: Two weeks.
EMILY: Yeah.
MATT: Bye bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]